winter storm Jonas is hitting the East
Coast this weekend hard yeah yeah you've
heard this before and you've gotten
burned but too many forecasts are
aligning for this one to be a fluke some
northeastern cities are supposed to get
more than a foot and a half of snow to
be one of the worst storms to hit DC in
almost a decade what's behind the storm
first a cold high pressure system sets
up shop in the northeastern coast at the
same time a big low pressure system
develops over the middle of the country
that low pressure system keeps building
and moving up the southern coast and
then moving up up up until it smacks
into the stagnant high pressure system
when they do finally meet the pressure
difference draws in tons of moisture
which eventually get to dump down on you
in the form of snow it's not just the
snow you have to worry about sure there
will be paralyzing traffic and transit
shutdowns but places like New York the
Jersey Shore in the Chesapeake Bay are
also anticipating major potentially
hurricane like flooding thanks to the
storm surge on top of naturally high
tides could be even worse than a
hurricane because this storm is expected
to last over three high tide cycles the
storm won't limit its effect to coastal
cities either the Gulf Coast is getting
extreme rainfall and places like eastern
Arkansas it's back to major ice
accumulation inhale basically get ready
for a long weekend stuck inside